WHY WON'T THAT BABY STOP CRYING?!
Girl, he don't want you gettin' it!
Hey babies, Trace here for DNews!
Thanks for watching!
Part of being a new parent is dealing with
a wailing infant, sacrificing sleep and sanity
to keep the new creature calm, warm, quiet,
and fed.
A new study in the journal Evolution, Medicine
and Public Health is bringing the reality
of your little bundle of selfishness to light!
Babies don't want siblings!
Think about it, if your baby is screaming
and crying, that's not exactly the sexiest
environment for making ANOTHER baby.
If you're taking care of your baby you're
not in the bedroom gettin' freaky.
It's genius!
BABIES ARE TINY GENIUSES!
Which explains their big heads, I guess...
Newborns want to EAT every 2-3 hours.
Evolutionarily, newborn eating means breast-feeding.
There have been numerous studies showing the
hormones, antibodies and nutrients passing
from the mother to the child during breast-feeding.
Breast-feeding has also been connected to
hormonal changes responsible for a lack of
motherly ovulation.
No eggs, no new babies!
Turns out, over the first year of life, the
newborn's crying habits can change, depending
on the genes it inherited from the parents.
Certain genes from dad would cause the baby
to cry MORE and keep the mother awake longer,
because when living in the wild, it's not
in the father's best interest to have the
mother ovulate again, because she could be
impregnated by a competing male!
We've talked about the effect of birth order
on DNews, so you might recall, the firstborn
gets 100 percent of the parent's resources!
That monopoly has huge developmental advances,
so it's not just in the best interest of a
dad to keep the mom from breeding again, but
the kid too!
As humans moved away from our ancient, natural,
existence into this modern one we stopped
breeding as much as possible and hoping some
survive, and instead ensure the survival of
every kid we birth!
Who does that?
That is a very different evolutionary imperative.
This conversation inevitably finds its way
to a simple evolutionary question: Why would
we evolve super loud babies if we're hiding
from predators in the wild?!
Chimpanzee babies wail too, bird babies are
noisy, even insect babies have learned attention-getting
behavior.
It might attract predators, but rather more
importantly, it gets the parents attention
to feed, protect, warm, or comfort it.
Some scientists feel wailing sends evolutionary
signals to parents the baby is fighting for
survival -- and is vigorous.
I couldn't find any science explaining some
predatory disadvantage to wailing, but considering
the number of species that DO IT, it's probably
no thang.
We'll have to see.
In the end, hunger and sexual discouragement
is just one of many reasons babies will wail
through the night, they'll also cry to announce
their pain, anger, or fear.
A study in the Spanish Journal of Psychology
looked at infant's subtle body language to
find which.
For example, open-eye crying means fear or
anger, closed-eye crying is pain.
Babies are pretty smart little buggers, messing
with their parents sexual cycles, sleep cycles
and food cycles.
Many parents debate the best way to respond
to crying, and I'm not here to settle THAT,
but over time primates respond less and less
to their babe's wailing, and the kid learns
to do things on their own.
You humans will just have to decide for yourself.
Babies are weird, and they're gross and they're
something else...
Beautiful maybe?
If you like things that are weird, gross and
beautiful click here to see my friend Catie
Wayne's show about weird, gross and beautiful
things!
It's fun and cute and fun every week.
How do you feel about babies after this?
Tell us in the comments below, and subscribe
for more weird news.
Plus, I'm on Twitter!
Come find me at-TraceDominguez!